hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game that was played today I
finished like an hour ago between Arjun
irrigation and Dennis Abel from the
European Club cup uh it's a game that
features many uh well maybe maybe we can
call them mistakes maybe inaccuracies
you guys will be the judge of that but
it will also feature two very nice
positive video moments uh as the
positions are quite wild now before we
check out the game I would just like to
mention that I am almost ready to start
my next Saga for those of you who don't
know it will be the Saga about uh
Wilhelm Stein it's the the first
official world champion uh so uh stay
tuned for that I should probably start
it uh at the beginning of the next week
but maybe even sooner than that so we'll
see I know you guys have been uh waiting
for for the next big Saga and it's been
quite a while since uh The morphe Saga
finished so uh yes it is coming uh so
here we have Arjun education with the
white pieces playing German
international Master Dennis Abel now
let's check it out and then we are going
and discuss uh well the live standings
the live ratings and whatnot so here
Ponte E4 and we have Pawn to C6 uh
Dennis goes for the Karo Khan defense
and now D4 striking in the center I
would also just like to mention that
I've seen a very very cool idea for
white um where white plays D3 and uh
it's uh I've tried it uh several uh
leeches games and it works wonders
against pretty much any uh rating you
you can play against two thousand twenty
one hundred twenty two thousand twenty
two hundred twenty three twenty four so
it really does wonders and when black
strikes in the center you can go Knight
F3 and after the characters I need for
you will Knight to G5 so uh capturing
and D3 that is what the most people will
play as it is the best move by the
engine let's say Bishop captures on D3
and it's a pretty standard position
where white uh gave up a pawn and black
is better but almost everyone plays
Knight to F6 here and black can now
resign so it's a really a A peculiar
position where almost everyone plays
this move and then you just capture an
F7 and that's it King captures Bishop to
G6 check and now the king cannot go back
to help out with the defense of the
queen and that's pretty much it king or
age cappers Queen capture 78 and your
upper Queen so uh you you can try it if
you want if you're you know if you're an
E4 player you don't like playing against
the Karo Khan you get weird positions
try the D3 line instead of the D4 line I
don't know it might it might work
wonders for you but okay in this game uh
of course these guys are very
professional and serious they play the
good stuff we have D4 D5 and now E5
Arjun goes for the advanced variation of
the Karo Khan with Bishop to F5 uh
developing the bishop before closing the
structure and now H4 Arjun goes for the
tal variation of the uh of this uh well
Advanced variation of the Karo Khan as
Mikhail tal has popular popularized it
uh quite a lot in his day so here h6h5
is the more popular nowadays he plays H6
and now G4 going after the bishop Bishop
to e for F3 pushing the bishop back
Bishop to H7 and now this very standard
idea of E6 it's a very standard like I
said not nothing new here and of course
you don't capture there that would be
pretty pointless you just weakened this
diagonal uh you know you're going to
trade of the light Square Bishops then
put the queen and D3 and black will be
in a lot of trouble so basically the
main moves here are Knight to F6 and
queen to D6 and in the game we have
Knight to F6 and now uh just the bishop
to D3 again capturing doesn't really do
all that much
uh for example if you capture King
captures uh the problem is yes G5 looks
very nice but after G5 captures captures
there's this very annoying Bishop
captures on C2 move attacking the queen
and the rook and yes now you have to
play Queen captures here and after Rook
captures on H1 uh what do you play uh
well Queen G1 of course you go a queen
g2go after the rook and after Rook to H4
you can pick up the Knight but after e
captures and F6 you get this position uh
where black has two Rooks of Bishop and
then uh Bishop in the Knight and white
has two Bishops two knights and one Rook
so it would be fairly equal but nothing
to two advantages for white so instead
just Bishop to D3 continuing development
uh Queen to D6 like I said and now e
captures an F7 only after the queen was
in D6 so King captures and now Knight to
E2 uh just uh steadily developing Knight
beat the D7 and now there are some games
where Bishop captures and H7 was played
but here Arjun plays Knight beat the C3
and it is now already as of movie 11
that we have a completely new game so
here Ponte E5 then it strikes in the
center and it of course it makes sense
the white king is still in the center of
the board D captures an E5 Arjun
captures and now Knight captures on E5
putting pressure on this F3 Pawn so
Arjun just Castle you could also
consider King to F2 if you want to have
the Rook remain on the h f file but
Arjun castles Rook to E8 now and the
bishop captures on H7 okay Rook captures
and King G2
adding another Defender here and it now
comes Pawn to G6 Pawn to G5 is also very
interesting here because you're asking
what do you do if you capture then you
give me the H file for my rook and if
you advance the pawn then black can just
hide the king and now or this Pawn
structure is basically a very good
shield for for the black king and you
will put
um uh the the nice to some very very
interesting squares uh for example these
two squares are are very weak in White's
Camp so it's gonna be it's not going to
be pleasant playing this with white but
okay in the game we have G6 keeping
things uh open and flexible Knight to G3
by Arjun and now King to G8 playing very
very correctly uh uh by Dennis we have
Knight C to E2 and now Pawn to H5 we
have Pawn to G5 Knight F to D7 and now
Ponte F4 preparing uh to advance the
pawn even further Knight the G4 and now
comes Pawn to F5 here we have Rook H2 E7
doubling up on the E file and here uh
Arjun or by playing F5 he freed up the
F4 Square for his Knight and Knight to
F4 is the move you want to play here but
he plays Bishop to F4 attacks the black
queen and now there is a problem there
is a sort of a winning line here for
Dennis so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find this critical idea
while I give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations as you have found a
move both of them have missed and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is a rook captures an E2 with
check now I will just uh quickly fix
something so stay tuned for that I know
you guys uh always say that I should
show this in classical games so just
give me a few seconds uh just to give
you an example of the the rating
difference between the two gentlemen uh
let me just fix this real quickly
yeah because there is quite quite the
difference all right let me just save
this
there we go all right so uh as Arjun is
much much higher rated than his opponent
uh it also makes sense that his opponent
trusted Arjun in this situation that
there really isn't a tactical shot here
but Rook captures I need you really is a
problem the problem for white is that
after Knight captures on E2 which is the
only move Knight to E3 check and now the
king rook and queen are forked here so
you have to capture the Knight Bishop
captures and Rook captures and it seems
like okay maybe white can survive this
maybe it's not that bad you do have the
pawns I mean it's a nice position but
there's no move for white uh with the
rook and queen controlling the G3 Square
white can never move the knight from E2
once you move it it's game over uh so
what can you play here not all that much
there there's no more you can make that
with
um make it playable for white because
once the once the queen moves the Knight
is coming to E5 the bishop is coming to
C5 this is just terrible even if you try
to trade off the Rooks just captures
captures and queen H2 again just Bishop
C5 Knight the E5 check is coming look at
the in covering all of these squares the
pawn covering G for this Pawn covering
E4 once this bishop to C5 and 95 land
that's that's just game over so this is
what uh Arjun missed and the Dennis
trusted him that there is nothing in the
position so never never ever trust your
opponents even if they are over 2700 So
here Knight D to E5 was played adding
another attacker into the game and now
Arjun was very much relieved as he
pushed F6 and now his position is all of
a sudden better so here Rook the D7 if
you go to E6 then just Knight E4 attacks
The Rook um
so you have to I mean that would be
pointless let's look to D7 now C3 and
here we have Pawn to C5 preparing to
push further in the center and now King
to G1 by Arjun uh you could also play
the the the the sharp uh Bishop captures
with the idea of bringing the queen to
D3 and going after the G6 spawn and if
Knight captures an E5 now you can bring
your knight to F4 again put pressure on
this pawn and then maybe you can even
sacrifice it pick up the the H5 Pawn
many possibilities here but okay King to
G1 was played and now comes Queen to
sorry Queen to C6 uh and here uh finally
Bishop captures on E5 the queen does not
belong on C6 uh but after Bishop
captures an E5 Knight captures Here
Comes Knight to F4 putting pressure on
the two pawns with C for now and here
Arjun plays Knight G to E2 uh the the
capturing and G6 is again uh very much
winning for arjune for example Knight
captures Queen capture address there's
just no good way to defend this position
it's a completely unplayable you can't
defend the Knight and if you move then I
just just G6 F7 I mean black falls apart
so it's uh it's very very mysterious
that Arjun did not play this I don't
know the exact time they had in in this
position but it does seem like a move
that he will be will find but okay not
the GT2 maybe he knows that he can't
really lose this and he was in worse
possession so maybe he is uh you know
maybe a subconscious maybe dumpling his
position or something but okay here
Bishop to C5 with check again uh D4 was
was slightly better here because now we
have knighted the D4 and queen to D6 now
if the position opens up the queen has
access to G3 it should be very nice uh
Queen to D2 and now Bishop captures on
D4 we have C captures on D4 and now
Knight to D3 offering a pawn here trying
to get Arjun away from the G6 explore
and interestingly Arjun does not capture
on G6 he goes after the D3 Knight which
again equalizes the position captures
captures and Rook to E4 not allowing in
any uh a queen G6 action anytime soon
Rook F2 preparing to double up on the
file and now King the F7 so now the G6
Pawn is nicely defended Rook to C1 it
will be pointless to double up on the f
file now and here comes Queen to E6
putting a lot of pressure on the E file
uh Queen to F3 you cannot defend the H
for Pawnee if you play something like
Queen here then Rook G4 traps the queen
so of course Arjun decides to give it up
he plays Queen to F3 he has to try
something if he doesn't win he's gonna
lose a lot of rating for a draw so Rook
captures on H4 and now comes Rook to E2
attacking the queen here Rook the G4
check King to F2 and now we have Queen
to D6 again with Queen to F5 uh you just
uh trade down into into into a better
end game because after Queen captures G
captures yes okay there are four Rooks
on the board but uh I mean these two
pawns will fall whatever you play even
if you go after this Pawn just throw
captures and G5 and now if let's say
Rook C8 King captures and F6 it's not
gonna be easy two past spawns uh Arjun
would have to fight uh you know like
like a lion to defend this but okay
Queen to D6 was played keeping
everything open the the white king is a
bit uh more loose than the black king
but still so Rook the E5 not allowing
any infiltrating ideas with the black
queen and here you have to play either
Rook captures on D4 this is fine or you
play Queen to B6 other moves are not all
that great for black so here Queen the
B4 was played and it seems like a move
that you should be able to play because
you're still putting pressure on this
you're still keeping an eye on these
seven Pawn twice if some rookie seven
action happens you're threatening Rook
the C2 D2 check the pick of the rook and
C1 so why wouldn't Queen going to be for
work well feel free to pause the video
and win the game for Arjun now while I
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
brilliancy and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is a rook the
E7 check yes I know I tricked you saying
that that's uh very well guarded but
that's exactly why I said it because now
you can't not take if you if you just
move the king then the other route comes
into play Rook C to check and after one
move it's Checkmate so you have to
capture The Rook the problem is after
Rook captures an E7 Arjun plays F
captures on E7 and now the king is in
check you do not have Queen captures on
E7 so now it's a king hunt and it
doesn't matter if you capture or not if
you move the king then just Queen f8
check and you Checkmate the the black
ink quickly and if King captures an E7
that was played in the game then Queen
to F6 check this is what makes it also
possible King D7 Queen to F7 check King
to d8 and here just Queen to C7 check
and it was in this position and move 43
that Dennis Abel resigned the game as
there was nothing more to be done here I
believe end of the game uh yeah Arjun
had one minute 53 seconds on the clock
and the Dennis had two minutes and 38
seconds on the clock so they were very
much Valentine and time control was
barely reached a a few moves ago as this
move uh 43. so yeah uh Arjun even
doesn't go for the for the quick
Checkmate uh for example uh here after
this uh uh King to d8 move you could
just play Queen captures on D5 and it's
an Instant Checkmate King 8 Queen the E6
check King to f8 Rook C8 check King G7
and uh now Queen captures on G8 but uh
he was low on time and of course he
wasn't uh forced to find it so he just
finished with a nice Queen the C7 check
which also runs into pretty much the
same thing just Queen the C8 check and
the pawn here really does a good job of
keeping the black king and Bane now
there are no more squares for the black
king you have to put a queen in between
so here you can just capture it let's
say captures captures and okay it's not
Checkmate but it's pointless to continue
that's why decided to play it this way
instead of going for the force the mate
and so I don't forget here are the
standings uh let me just find that uh
yeah I believe this so so you can see
that uh Magnus again with a minus next
to his name uh because Magnus is also
playing in this event and he did not uh
I was not I was unable to win he drew a
game
he played against Nikita meshkov so
flight VR and he was uh he had the black
pieces and there was just no way to ask
any questions there so yeah
congratulations to Nikita and holding
magnets to a drawing a classical game
and you can see that a lot of points
that he lost getting closer and closer
to that second place being lyron uh then
uh not much change all the way up to uh
number 11 on and dropped a few points as
well obviously he drew the game uh Arjun
Erica AC plus four points for this and
now he's again 18 and gookish is number
19. so the two of them this one wins the
game then Arjun wins the game then
gookish wins then Arjun and they are you
know uh well it's a very very good that
they are uh fighting against each other
to you know up up the raiding game as
that will bring them closer to the likes
of grishek
look at this a 27-47 by uh by Dominguez
of mvl karaoke in her job of
Ender Java so a lot of upon 2747 so yeah
many more games need to be won by Gucci
and Arjun at uh to reach that but once
they do that they're getting close to
the world top 10 so it's going to be
very exciting to see what they will do
in the European Club Cup this year uh so
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it big congratulations to
everyone who spotted both pause the
video moments now there were a lot of
mistakes here uh and it's very weird
that Arjun missed all of this because
you give him one one a little
opportunity I mean he just
takes advantage of it and he crushes
everyone I think it's due to the fact
that he's playing against the lower
rated player so I I don't think he's uh
invested in the game as much I mean uh
he he maybe felt a bit overconfident or
something because it's it's quite the
quite a drastic I mean uh difference
that over 300 rating points but yeah in
the end he won so very very nicely done
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it I would like to thank James
daughter and Lubbock whereas I got
materno home totally I love you and Alan
uh Bradbury for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here and thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World and yes the steinit Saga
will start very soon so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day